con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la operación militar
del gobierno de Turquía contra las
milicias kurdas en respuesta al atentado
del pasado 13 de noviembre que causó
seis muertes en Estambul y el que el
gobierno Turco acusa a esos grupos según
el Ministerio de defensa de Turquía han
sido atacados casi 500 objetivos o
kurdos en el norte de Irak y Siria
Mientras que el presidente hay perdón
habla cada vez más seguido de la
posibilidad de una nueva incursión
terrestre como la ocurrida en el año
2019 ya lo vamos entonces Agustín Berea
él es académico de la universidad
iberoamericana maestro en estudios de
Asia y África Agustín gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de miércoles aquí en directo
América de Francia 24 empecemos para dar
un contexto de Quiénes son los kurdos y
cuál es su importancia estratégica en
esa región y porque el presidente Turco
revienta ahí perdovan los puso en el
punto de mira y los apuesto desde
siempre no
la relación entre
erdogan y los crudos han sido complicado
De hecho cuando llega erdogan al poder
inicialmente lo hacen una coalición
compartidos nacionalistas kurdos los
kurdos forman una parte sustancial de la
población de turquías son
aproximadamente el 20%, pero en la parte
Sur pues son la mayoría entonces después
de 2015 que hay una ruptura entre
erdogan Y estos partidos de mayoría
curva es que se ha deteriorado la
relación y cada vez que hay elecciones
en Turquía suele haber estas escaladas
de violencia tenemos elecciones
presidenciales en Turquía en 2023
entonces todo indica que sí está
retórica Y estos ataques pues
seguramente seguirán Agustín porque los
ve como una amenaza Y por qué también
como lo decíamos en nuestra introducción
al tema el presidente de Turquía digamos
está cada vez más cerca más amenazante
con esta posible incursión a territorio
sirio donde se encuentra esta población
kurda
tenemos que leerlas las acciones y las
declaraciones de erdogan siempre como un
mensaje de política interna entonces
realmente lo que parece es que erdogan
está intentando darle servicio a sus
bases a las bases como más Ultra
nacionalistas
dentro de Turquía entonces este tipo de
de bravado de decir sí Ahora sí vamos a
acabar con la con La amenaza de los
terroristas kurdos sirve muy bien para
ganar este tipo de electorado pensando
en las elecciones del próximo año y el
segundo factor es que en este momento el
otro jugador grande dentro de
de Siria que es Rusia está un poco
ocupado con otros asuntos Entonces si
hay algún momento en el que Turquía
podrías proyectar su poder en Siria es
ahorita que Rusia está ocupado y que
erdogan necesita ganarse esos
ultranacionalistas claro ahora erduana
digamos con esta guerra contra los
kurdos pero la cosa es diferente digamos
en la mirada de Estados Unidos que apoya
a estas milicias kurdas porque
recordemos que ellos también empezaron
una lucha contra el autodenominado
estado islámico entonces hay dos
preguntas en esta parte del de la
historia digamos o porque ellos
empezaron una lucha contra el denominado
estado islámico por cuestión de
territorio y luego ya porque lo apoya
Estados Unidos O para tratar de acabar
con este grupo terrorista
inicialmente o bueno oficialmente
el apoyo hacia los kurdos sirios y
también a los kurdos iraquíes que son
dos grupos digamos políticamente
ideológicamente distintos pero Estados
Unidos apoya a estos grupos en el Irak
en el cortistán iraquí en contra de
Sadam husein y después en el en el
kurdistán sirio en contra de bachar al
azar Entonces los kurdos en general se
han sido buenos aliados de Estados
Unidos como
digamos son las botas en el en el campo
que Estados Unidos no va a mandar pero
que sí puede digamos actuar por a través
de ellos Entonces si Estados Unidos
tiene una buena coordinación con ellos
por supuesto que que los kurdos sirios
fueron instrumentales para derrotar al
estado islámico pero hoy por hoy no
sabemos hasta qué grado la
administración vaiden y después en 2024
cuando tengamos las elecciones qué tanto
puede haber la la voluntad política en
Estados Unidos para mantener esa Alianza
con los kurdos sirios y sacrificar la
relación con Turquía Ese es la gran
pregunta Estados Unidos estaría
dispuesto a sacrificar la relación con
Turquía Eso depende de la Administración
o que esté de turno Más allá de una
política de estado estadounidense
sí En mi opinión si ha cambiado mucho la
no sé si lo recordarás pero en durante
la administración Trump Incluso se
pretendía sacar todo tipo de apoyo a los
kurdos sirios y que sí Se recibió con
con mucho con mucho malestar pero sí fue
una decisión de de Trump tal cual y y Sí
en un escenario futuro podríamos ver si
regresa a Trump por Si regresa algún
otro personaje con este tipo de
proyectos
desde razón dentro de Estados Unidos y
podríamos pensar que podría pasar de
nuevo y que Estados Unidos
definitivamente le da la espalda a sus
aliados puros claro y profundizó sobre
este tema porque pues ya hubo un
pronunciamiento una carta dirigida por
parte de los kurdos al presidente de
Estados Unidos en este momento Joe vayan
diciendo que Donald Trump en su momento
los había traicionado pero que ahora con
administración de Joe biden pues las
cosas seguían de alguna manera igual
cree que va a haber un pronunciamiento
oficial de la Casa Blanca ante este
llamado de la población kurda
lo veo poco probable Sí veo más probable
que hayan pronunciamientos dentro del
senado
particularmente de los de los grupos
demócratas Pero bueno también
republicanos pero lo más probable no sea
tanto un pronunciamiento dentro de la
Casa Blanca sino dentro del Congreso
estadounidense ahí sí creo bastante más
probable que haya un pronunciamiento
para presionar a la administración a que
a que atiende este asunto Agustín
también estas poblaciones son atacadas
desde Irán le pregunto por qué Y ya
también para ir finalizando nuestra
conversación Nunca van a tener un estado
de los kurdos
es una pregunta un poco complicada y la
respuesta muy pronto es que parece que
no hay las condiciones para que se
genere un nuevo estado que sea el estado
curvo por lo menos lo que hemos visto en
Siria y en Irak después del procesos muy
violentos es que los kurdos han logrado
por la fuerza tener una autonomía
sustancial que les permita por lo menos
hablar su propio idioma tener sus
autonomía en temas de Educación en temas
de economía entonces la idea de un
estado acordo se ve muy poco probable
pero si lo que sucede en el coordistán
iraquí que es un es una región bastante
bastante Autónoma si se podría ver en el
futuro y se está viendo en Siria en
Turquía se ve menos probable pero sería
el escenario que podemos decir es más
probable más que un estado